[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
dans le dernier numéro savait que les
femmes avaient pris le pouvoir et t4 les
mecs sont revenus en france
il reste quand même un bon jour ces gens
vivent des émissions avec ce qui était
très bien servi d'accueillir françois
boulianne vous êtes conseil en stratégie
en développement commercial est alors
passionne vous êtes au fond un spécial
de la communication on pourrait dire ça
ça en fait partie des vecteurs et vous
avez fondé le yvelines business club
alors qui regroupe des débats des chefs
d'entreprise des yvelines
racontez nous un petit peu tout à fait
l'objectif c'est de vraiment réunir des
dirigeants des décideurs de la région de
l'ouest francilien
autour d'eux des jeunes et une fois par
mois et avec un intervenant extérieur
vraiment avec un une sirène parcours de
vie exceptionnelle nous avons reçu
martine monteil pour avoir quelques
extraits qui hante à l'heure c'était
c'est tout récent un oui et c'est vrai
que l'ancienne patronne de la pythie
voilà tout à fait logique arias
exceptionnel réactionnaire la police
comme une des seules femmes la première
pour la première fois dans lequel il ya
eu d'autres femmes mais par contre elle
était dans des services de renseignement
donc les apparaissent pas jeudi à au
devant de la scène a été la première
médiatisé et en plus c'est là une
carrière complètement exceptionnel quoi
jean baptiste du clerck
bonjour bonjour patrice j'enseignais
toujours à l'université de versailles
saint quentin
j'ai oublié de dire que certaines
enseignes toujours à sciences po la
magie du bronze et jean-charles le jeudi
bonjour ça va bien vous des éditeurs
toujours jouer
et voilà le dernier livre que vous payez
qui s'appelle d oublier un petit
chef-d'oeuvre
comme tout ce match local n ya pas un
peu comme tout ce qu'on publie t
vraiment très très bien
oui et c'est de ces deuxième livre de
manica gagna qu avait auparavant gagné
quelques concours de nouvelles et c'est
le deuxième livre qu'on publie de lui et
c'est un très bon roman policier qui
mixe une histoire de deux vieux musicien
qui a disparu avec une histoire de de
gens de sdf et 2 et de migrants c'est
assez assez habile c'est en effet
l'heure actuelle ce actuelle est très
très intelligemment combiné donc
consommer de les oublier oublier ce qui
est aussi le titre d'un album du
chanteur qui s'appelle gauvin serre
voilà un film de bunuel d'oublier
justement revenons à l'elysée ce club
donc vous avez reçu martine monteil
on va regarder un petit extrait plus
reparlé après martine monteil donc
ex-patron de la pj qui m'a donné aussi
cette légitimité
je parle de ça parce que la jauge
anticipe que je suis arrivé jusqu'à
directeur du quai des orfèvres et
ensuite même directeur central de la
police judiciaire c'est-à-dire pour
toute la france
le 36 quai des orfèvres c'est paris et
les trois départements de la couronne et
la dcpj
c'est toute la france plus notre mère
etc
donc voyez j'aurais pu être avocat
jean-pierre magistrat bah non c'est
quand même policier qui l'intéressait
c'est le côté chasseurs cette traque
cette étude sinon les en première ligne
les voyous le magistrat il les a c'est
prémâché tout a été fait
il leur reste qu'à les mettre en prison
bon ça si seulement ils pouvaient le
faire plus souvent
elle est drôle beaucoup d'humour assez
grinçant par moments par contre une
expérience est complètement exceptionnel
où elle avait raconté des liens dans un
livre comment enfin voilà comment ce
fait être le chef d'un milieu qui quand
même un milieu de domme constat chez
google ou stressés et elle a réussi
d'ailleurs accepté ce que nous a exprimé
c'est le fait qu'elle soit qu'elles
aient toujours été sur le terrain
elle a démarré comme stagiaire et en
plus dans son expérience elle a eu je
passion dit la chance mais en tout cas
sur sa trajectoire 3 serial killer donc
ce qui est complètement exceptionnel
dans la vie surtout en francs curiae
george vi georgie a eu le l'étrangleur
du 12e d'abord et puis mamadou traoré
qui assassine et les femmes à coups de
poing c'était très très violent et donc
en france est assez exceptionnelle et
elle a toujours obtenu sa légitimité en
étant sur le terrain ça c'est ce que oui
ça m'a impressionné peut-être une fois
de plus dans les bureaux a été très long
elle était vraiment au contact de la
réalité quoi tout doux le respect
qu'elle qu'elle a obtenu deux des
enquêtes ce qu'elle nous a exprimé
également c'est le fait que l a jamais
joué le mec entre guillemets très
féminine
sur les photos elle sur le livre un flic
simplement il ya eu une série tv
oui selon les dévier un tir beaucoup de
charisme en tout cas donc ça fait partie
de ces personnalités que vous
j'avais dans le business club au mois de
mai nous recevons patrick puy qui est le
pdg du groupe e vivarte donc monsieur
qui a parfois une invitation a séduit
par contre il va nous écrire et le fait
comment on fait pour eux d'aller c'est
un groupe qui est complètement au bord
de la faillite
donc ça c'est exceptionnel parce que
également c'est on peut en tirer des
enseignements même à plus petite échelle
désormais pas commettre et quand on est
en crise comment on fait comment passez
au delà de la crise et nous avons comme
parrain exceptionnel qui viendra qui
sera présent notre déjeuner du mois
d'octobre
franck mesnel qui a démarré sa carrière
en fait dans les yvelines à
saint-germain-en-laye avait avancé une
carrière de rugbyman international mais
et co-fondateur d'ee du parc oui c'est
ça après le mans on allie sport très
haut niveau business
donc c'est ça qui est super intéressant
qu'il marque qui marche très bien oui
désolé quitter d'abord un peu les la
marque des rugbymans expliquer ces
phénomènes et d'exister un peu et
haricots complètement tout à fait alors
martine mon père disait les magistrats
bah ouais il reste qu'elle reste plus
qu'à bête de cirque ont arrêté entre les
eaux il devrait d'ailleurs les battre un
peu plus est c'est peut-être content de
travailler au japon car leur parle un
peu de carlos ghosn qui est qui a été
donc remis en prison des conditions
quand même quand on parle parfois on dit
la justice française est en crise
qu'elle marche pas très bien mais on a
l'impression que quand même que par fera
d'autres pics comme des démocraties
elle est quand même plus respectueuse
des droits des uns et des autres oui oui
et non parce que il ya deux choses c'est
d'abord ce que je trouve amusant c'est
que carlos ghosn
il se plaint du japon d'être traité en
fait il est traité comme tout comme un
japonais de base donc il est traité
comme tout le monde donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils seraient traités différemment
d'un japonais je ne suis pas la taupe
japon il a commis des soupçons d'avoir
commis des infractions au japon donc
c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils soient
embastillés dans la même prison va pas
faire une prison spéciale pour car le
nom donc on a l'impression que il ya
quand même pression de la justice
japonaise pour obtenir des aveux pour
enfin pour faire craquer quand même oui
mais c'est le principe même du 2 2 ce
qui se passe au japon et j'ai jamais
entendu carlos ghosn se plaindre du
japon quand il en en profiter quand il
en était quasiment levis empereur il n'a
jamais il s'est jamais plaint que le
japon leurs articles à peine de mort
beaucoup le plus souvent quasiment que
les états unis ce dont personne ne parle
je veux dire c'est quand même c'est que
alors tout d'un coup ils étaient ils
trouvent des que que japon c'est pas si
emballant que ça va il nous avait dit
que c'était très bien pendant des années
voilà qui profite des joies du japon et
des peines du japon se donnait pas mais
françois bouziane puisque vous voyez
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises des plus
grands chefs d'entreprise car la gauche
n'a fait appel
un peu au gouvernement français un
citoyen français est ce qu'on pouvait à
chaque fois répondu visiblement le
gouvernement le laisse dans la situation
où il est est-ce que c'est pas un
mauvais signal pour les chefs
d'entreprise y a que là on se place dans
un niveau aussi qui est très particulier
oui on est dans un empire dans des yeux
qui moi j'interviens beaucoup près de
deux pme
donc les gens sont complètement éloigné
de cette vision là moi j'ai fait des
parallèles aussi avec messier il ya
quelques années cette déchéance pour
pour rejoindre des propos c'est que
je pense qu'il préférait quand il était
un héros de manga et c'est un peu la
destitution est l'idole qu'on a porté
aux nues la lll et des dessous d'elle
est descendu et et le gouvernement est
aussi actionnaire de renault et donc je
pense qu'il ya aussi un travail de
communication pour le par le fait de ne
pas trop solidaire de carlos ghosn et
donc je crois qu'il est lâché tout
simplement d'huile ont lâché mais jude
et à ce que voilà selon moi le village
d'entreprises français il ya ce décalage
c'est que on parle de niveau de
rémunération parle de 2,2 on parle de
aussi de laquelle nous sommes pas loin
de versailles donc il ya des questions
sur l'utilisation des châteaux là on est
dans la démesure et on est très très
loin de ce que je connais de la vie d'un
dirigeant d'entreprise en france d'une
pme ou même d'une outils et oui mais je
crois qu'il ya trois choses dans cette
affaire la première c'est que je te
rejoins sur un point c'est qu'il faut
replacer cela dans le contexte du japon
la confiance elle est particulièrement
importante c'est une valeur le dirigeant
c'est un demi dieu est donc un abus de
confiance c'est c'est un crime d'état
ces voix là on pourrait pas avoir des
affaires comme on en a eu en france au
japon ça n'existe pas pour eux c'est
immoral c'est pire que tout il ya cette
première chose la deuxième à mon avis
c'est de replacer un petit peu dans le
droit pénal c'est que comme vous le
dites
même si le japon est une démocratie la
démocratie et démocratie on est la
patrie des droits de l'homme et on a
évidemment une procédure pénale bien
plus respectueuse des droits de la
défense que ce que tu es en train de
vivre carlos ghosn qui est détenu dans
des conditions qui sont quand même
pitoyable pour lequel il n'y a pas
vraiment présomption d'innocence chez
eux c'est-à-dire qu'on vous interroge à
l'envi on peut vouloir dès 22 heures en
garde à vue donc la troisième chose
c'est que je crois qu'il est vraiment
lâché parce que précisément on extrade
beaucoup de nos ressortissants est au
contraire on les rappelle très souvent
solide besoin les avoirs dans des
prisons françaises etc
et là comme par hasard on nous laisse
dans des conditions qui à mon sens ne
sont vraiment pas du tout proche de ce
qui se passe en france et de ce qu'il a
le droit d'avoir en tant que
ressortissant français alors on récupère
les les condamnés de du monde entier une
fois qu'ils ont été une fois qu'ils ont
été condamnés là il est toujours pas
condamné la donc lors pas toujours on
peut les récupérer en disant voilà on a
envie qu'ils suivent une procédure
pénale française parce que c'est notre
ressortissant et ici on s'arrange
beaucoup du fait que comme il était là
bas c'est la juridiction de la ma est à
mon avis assez profondément discuta mais
ça va avec ce déshonneur justement
japonais est aussi satisfaite le
classement compris dans son propre
groupe je crois que les deux vont perdre
tout le désistement sans répéter ce qui
a déjà été dit il c'est vrai que on
oublie parfois que lorsqu'on va dans un
pays étranger c'est
les lois de ce pays qui s'applique et
que on s'expose à des poursuites et un
système judiciaire qui est propre en cas
de de conflits et de manquement aux lois
du pays
donc après ces systèmes qui s'applique
le système japonais avec un modèle de
justice qui à certains égards ressemble
un petit peu modèle américain avec cette
mise en scène très importante qui me
choque beaucoup côté côté français bon
alors après on ne connaît pas les
tenants et les aboutissants de la faire
embrouiller difficilement lui dit que le
petit peu leur a pris mais ce qui peut
être aussi intéressant c'est d'observer
le comportement qui va être celui de
l'état français vis-à-vis de la
situation puisqu'il est vrai que c'est
un système qui est donc plutôt
démocratique est normalement lui l'état
français ne peut pas s'immiscer dans les
affaires intérieures donc de de ce pays
et puis de surcroît ne peut pas exiger
du pouvoir politique
d'obtenir quelque chose du domaine de la
justice séparation des pouvoirs il ya
donc ça va être intéressant de voir
comment le gouvernement va réagir ou ne
pas réagir à cette situation qu'il dit
là le titre trois nationalités donc il
peut aussi en appeler au brésil au liban
donc et puis mais j'aurais pdg de
renault voit la dame et son avis la
faire je sais pas si tu avais terminé
ton propos juste terminée sur le fait
que au delà de tout ce qu'on peut penser
d'affaires est de 2,2 carlos définit les
conditions de détention sont absolument
monstrueux s'est construit ça c'est pire
n y ait des conditions absolument
inhumaines
c'est très sportif vient pas souvent
parce que relais pour les enfants et
daria et le procès tapie par exemple
avec stéphane richard pdg d'orange qui
est donc contre lequel a été demandé une
peine de prison ferme
on entendait des salaires et d'orange
qui sont un peu inquiets évidemment par
sa pour renault est ce que la sphère est
déjà passé enfin la page de gauche n'ait
déjà tourné ou est ce que c'est un
et les gens changement aussi de l'image
un petit peu en justement c'est vraiment
le pdg il ne pouvait baiser prend un
salaire 450000 euros par an à s'amuser
ils ont annoncé qu'ils auraient pas sa
retraite au delà de tourner la page ils
ont fermé les livres
c'est un président normal il va avoir un
changement de management
il est très important et et puis en plus
l'on parle beaucoup de renault et
n'oublions pas initial l'action nissan
et les fortes dans cette histoire est en
tout cas c'est le noeud du problème est
à venir c'est même sa durée et renault
donc développement de renault doit
beaucoup aussi à celui de miss un
nouveau départ est en tout cas pour
avoir quelques amis qui sont acteurs
cherono à bon niveau là il ya un vrai
souffle nouveau et il y avait une vraie
attente parce que ma semaine de carlos
ghosn c'est quelque chose de très
difficile à vivre mais oui alors c'est
s'est toujours pas d'ailleurs le une
question qu'on peut se poser à skis
comme ça quand il ya des grands managers
des grands pdg on a l'impression qu'ils
sont unis qu'est ce qui sauve aussi
unique que ce qui a pourtant beaucoup de
gens qui pourraient faire à peu près la
même chose
est ce que ça vaut les sommes générées
on peut toujours dire on aimait bien les
maximes que personne n'est indispensable
enfin je veux dire toujours remplacer
quelqu'un par quelqu'un d'autre veut
dire
renault et nissan survivront à au départ
de karting et carlos tavares chez
peugeot visiblement enfin voila il a
quand même redresser l'entreprise
des défis mais après parce que pendant
quand ça fonctionne il viendrait à
personne de dire que d'abord tout le
monde est unique déjà annoncé par contre
là il ya eu des vraies vertus et il ya
une vraie impulsion
donc il ya une vraie politique sensé
plein jour nouveau où les grands groupes
pourrait dire ça fonctionne on attend
d'un chef puisque c'est carrément un
capitaine d'industrie
sinon ce qu'on attend c'est une vraie
vision politique et quand ça fonctionne
là il est bien unique il est bien
l'entraîneur après du système après
quand la statue se dévissent c'est bien
là tout le monde se contraignent le
système
donc est-ce que ça le vent c'est ce à
quoi un autre débat oui qu'est-ce qui va
quelque chose il ya un débat qui c'est
qui qui a lieu sur les retraites chapeau
il ya tom enders le patron d'airbus qui
va partir avec une trentaine de millions
là aussi le bruit de l'ovaire enfin le
gouvernement prévoit de limiter des
retraites chapeaux ce qui paraît très
facile je pense juridiquement mais
également des dispositions dans la loi
pacte justement sur la cei en paye sur
la manière dont les actionnaires
la loi qui est en discussion donc je
parle uniquement pour la privatisation
des aéroports de paris mais qui est une
loi monstre qui contient en fait
beaucoup de dispositions de
modernisation de l'entreprise dont celle
de d'assumer un écart-type raisonnable
entre les salaires des plus hauts
voilà un responsable de l'entreprise et
des pdg pour qui une forme de parité
je crois que ça va avec l'air du temps
en quelque sorte c'est à dire que en
politique c'est la même chose maintenant
on ne supporte plus les inégalités on a
un petit peu ce sentiment que il faut
arriver à une tout ce qui devient
exorbitant devient anormal est très mal
vécue je pense donc pas sa situation
opposant sa 10 mais vous aurez plus de
grands pdg en france enfin est ce que
[Musique]
cherchait quelqu'un d'extérieur qui a
fait augmenter beaucoup voilà
mais après faut aussi être honnête
vis-à-vis de tom enders c'est à dire que
tout le monde parle de cette somme
effectivement faramineuse de 36 millions
d'euros
mais c'est pas un chèque de 36 millions
d'euros qu'on va les faire c'est les 36
millions d'euros calculée sur une
espérance la vie à 85 ans et en a 60 se
croient ou 65 ans donc c'est calculée
sur 20 ans en unifiant par l'asse donc
36 millions / 20 ans on arrive peu ou
trop quand même à quelque chose de kaki
est quand même moins effrayant non
messieurs mais vous parle vous parliez
tout à l'heure du salaire du nouveau
patron de renault à 450000 euros etc
voilà là si on divise 36 millions par 25
ans on va arriver à un truc extrêmement
raisonnable mais enfin extrêmement
suffisant de l'everest le début c'est
pas ça paraît déjà moins choquant il
faut pas oublier ça c'est sûr et je sais
que tous les communes du plus bel effet
tout cuisiner sain parce qu'il ya deux
paradoxes aussi c'est que personne ne
reproche ou très peu les salaires des
footballeurs ou là on estime aussi qui
sont exceptionnelles sont des qualités
particulières et là on pourrait
s'interroger c'est cantilienne un
parachute doré
en cas de non résultats si ces indices
et sur un vrai boulot problème et je
suis là quand quelqu'un réussit a fait
grimper sa boîte et on peut admettre
mais c'est vrai que les parachutes
existe aussi pour des gens qui ont des
politiques - qui n'est pas
catastrophique je ne sais pas mais il ya
eu moins de résultats comme on est loin
du japon des noix de l'indu hara kiri
taton réussit pas vous perdez le réseau
s'en va parler des footballeurs mais si
c'est trois cent mille euros par jour
la rémunération des patrons qui y
beaucoup notre pays avec cette passion
française pour l'égalité on supporte
difficilement des écarts de revenu
complètement hallucinant et dans le même
temps c'est un petit peu mais les parce
qu'il ya aussi une sorte de fascination
pour les la culture du chef du grand
dirigeant chez les français que ce soit
en politique ou dans le domaine
économique donc à la france passionne on
admire et en même temps il ya cette
détestation puis sanitaire de richesses
qui sont évidemment très mal vécu et
surtout en ce moment mais c'est vrai que
ça pose une question philosophique est
ce que un homme peut valoir 20 x 30 x 40
x ce qu'on veut d'autres c'est sale ça
le pot des trouve alors si on indexe
effectivement là la réussite de la
rémunération sur la réussite si on a une
grande réussite et qu'on dirige un grand
navire effectivement ça peut être
considéré comme n'étant pas choquant
sauf à considérer que effectivement un
partage des richesses est complètement
nécessaire compte-tenu effectivement du
fait qu'on ne peut pas donner à la
hauteur d'un homme quelque chose qui
dépasse très des enfin qui sera auteur
de deux centaines de vies de smic
ouais effectivement c'est un
positionnement politique avec des
postulats de départ philosophique qui
qui sont propres à chacun un livre
sauvages et revient sur le mot c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient prononcées c'est la
valeur de l'homme vrai c'est en tout cas
on peut imaginer plus le résultat d'un
travail ou d'un apport de ce qu'il
produit et là c'est plutôt les les
distorsions d'échelle pour moi il ya
deux choses dans cette histoire de
carlos ghosn c'est la distorsion les
échelles et puis
l'effet exponentielle et la perte de
raison c'est à dire que ce extraits des
réalités humaines et la déchéance est
apparu quand ide et on le voit pas
descendre d où on voit descendre de son
jet privé
donc c'est cette distorsion et c'est
cette perte d'échelle et c'est ça c'est
ça c'est que ça provoque probable et et
comme l'être humain est complètement
paradoxale ça va quand c'est une idole
si c'est un rappeur côté ou un
footballeur donc là on a beau leur la
lave
l'excusé d'un tri mais les footballeurs
c'est dire leur carrière est courte mais
que penser alors de la valeur de
l'ex-femme de jeff bezos ce qui chez 34
milliards de dollars
donc là est ce que est ce que cette
femme là vaut plus qu'une autre
ap non m garnir de la tire bien joué
c'est pas des chats qu'ils avaient des
chats qui valent beaucoup c'est un essai
des siens soumet le stade de karl
lagerfeld
sadok la quatrième fortune du monde
enfin voila moi je crois que ça pose une
question si on part du postulat
philosophique ce pas c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
postulats de moralisation en politique
ou en droit c'est que à mon avis c'est
quelque chose de profondément
personnelle personne n'a obligé carlos
ghosn à avoir autant d'argent on peut
redistribuer c'est bien le gandhi avait
pas demandé à être payé donc là aussi
c'est une valeur personnelle ça vient
avec la propre morale de la personne qui
reçoit cet argent les conseils
d'administration toutes imposées dans de
validation il n'est pas tout seul à
avoir décidé d'un non de survie non mais
je veux dire voilà si c'est vraiment si
on part d'un postulat philosophique
c'est un postulat personnel avant tout à
mon avis on que la valeur de quelque
chose encore une fois ça doit être
indexée sur le travail si le travail
rémunéré c'est très bien et la personne
elle même si elle a cette idée qu'il
faut une égalité elle peut aussi
redistribuer ces choses-là existe
si ce fait est que nouveau pdg notamment
de renault il ya un certain nombre de
tués dans les entreprises de vouloir les
imiter le revoilà de redistribuer les
bénéfices d'être un petit peu dans la
philanthropie d'entreprise c'est quelque
chose qui est dans l'air du temps
en tout cas si c'est indexés sur une
certaine réussite c'est pas tellement
choquant voilà oui c'est ce que disait
voilà le sting qui réussissent aux
employés licenciés trois cent mille
personnes et qu'en plus vous partez avec
ce qui est arrivé est un fait que les
100 millions d'euros est évoqué les
jeunes curieux je pense que puisque l'on
était dans un débat plus macro nous
sommes aussi attrapé je m'assieds l'air
du temps dans tout cas me rattraper par
par ce qui se passe sur la planète c'est
à dire que on est confronté non plus à
l'infini mais en tout cas des des
restrictions c'est à dire des
restrictions de ressources et on est
loin des années 80 où tout paraît si
l'ère tapie où on pouvait monter comme
ça jusqu'au ciel dans des rémunérations
folles n'y avait pas de limites
et aujourd'hui je pense que les
générations qui arrivent
est-ce que dès le plus jeune âge
confronté aux limites et donc c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il ya peut-être plus de ses
possibilités à ça on sait que tout est
fini donc il va falloir partager les
ressources et vient du général qu'est ce
qui est de regarder le débat sur les
européennes
très clairement il ya tenu jusqu'au bout
au couteau je suis très fatigué donc je
peux répondre positivement
vous avez tout faux nez jusqu'au bout
françoise hier j'ai regardé et
le point d'interrogation que je peux
avoir c'est ce que c'est un débat parce
que c'est pas débat le débat pour moi
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est à dire qu'on a un temps de
parole chaque qui n'est pas contrôlée et
fêtera pour savoir si un qui parle plus
que retourner
il ya deux choses qui me sont apparus
sais que ce que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant c'est qu'il ya en plus dans
les nouvelles générations enfin
l'amélioration je sais pas si on peut
dire ça comme ça mais on nous avions
deux philosophes qui sont des débatteurs
par le fait qu'ils sont habitués à
débattre sur le fond est confronté à des
gens qui sont lavés bellamy et plus fun
le rafale wissmann donc ça je trouve ce
signal vieux aussi intéressant c'est que
peut-être qu'on recherche plus de fonds
qu'avant et il était confronté à des
spécialistes de la petite phrase ou du
coupage de parole est d'ailleurs raphaël
gutman a exprimé le fait à l'issue de
l'émission qu'il n'était pas fait pour
ça et bellamy c'est le seul qui n'ait
interrompu personnes
oui c'est parce qu'elle a marqué des
points c'est ça c'est gros plus il
faudrait il est plutôt été en 20 mai
mais c'est vrai que ça pose deux
problèmes de l'exercice cet exercice là
je crois que france télévisions avait
d'abord d'ailleurs décidé au départ de
pains vite et tout le monde
ils ont eu un recours devant le tribunal
administratif qui les a ou d'y inviter
tout le monde
le conseil d'état est revenue en arrière
en disant ils ont le droit et on n'est
pas dans la période de campagne
électorale proprement dites donc
une chaîne de télévision a le droit
d'inviter qu'il veut et puis ils n'ont
pas voulu se fâche et donc ils ont
invité tout le monde mais à douze
personnes parler d'un de problèmes comme
l'europe où il ya des des sujets un peu
complexe un peu technique c'est
impossible dans un peu l'impression d'un
remake politique de questions pour un
champion quoi d'aller chacun est
derrière son truc il faut apprendre à la
question que les autres gars dont vous
parlez pas de façade à mon avis aucun
aucun sens rajeunir personnes présentes
bien lieu deux heures de débat teyana
peler les étonnants de la petite phrase
qui coupent qui interrompent et c est
évidemment et qui force les autres un
peu parfois leur répondent parce qu'on
n'a pas envie de se faire insulter et
ceux qui restent dans leur dans leur
communication a rejoint complètement la
peau vision fait qu'il y avait aussi un
côté jeu télévisé avec des votes est
alors quand il ya la question était
posée sur glyphosate ou way we bought
majorité de verre tout le monde était
contre donc on est vraiment dans les
jeux où l'on voit chacun votés avec sa
tactile sa tablette
je crois qu'on est complètement loin de
sept îles pour moi paradoxal mais c'est
le propre de l'être humain c'est à dire
qu'on a des gens qui sont là sur le fond
qu'on laisse pas s'exprimer c'est à dire
qu'ils ont quelques secondes minutes sur
un sujet très important à la rejoindre à
autre chose parce qu'on a un peu de
temps et on peut laisser des gens
s'exprimer mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une
règle
de la télévision c'est on a peur de
faire chier les gens tout rendre au
concours pour van ozap
on zappe à la place des téléspectateurs
on n'a pas le temps de s'exprimer on n'a
pas le temps d'exprimer une idée 20,7
bien quand même ça devient comme
infernale c'était pas un débat d'idées
c'était un combat pour parler ça
vraiment se met alors on peut ne sais
pas si ça donne
voilà des élections sur lesquels il va y
avoir comme beaucoup d'abstentions et je
suis pas sûr que ce genre de débat de ne
pas encore d'une plus une mauvaise idée
de des élections que tout à fait
d'autant que 12 personnes c'est quand
même gigantesque et je suis absolument
persuadé que si on prenait les photos
des 12 participants et on demande à une
majorité de français de mettre un nom
sur chaque photo
mais ce serait un carnage quoi je veux
dire personne ne serait capable de dire
qui et nathalie oiseaux qui et jordan
bardella qui est machin là deux ou trois
qu'on connaît un peu mais sinon après
une baisse de 2 maelström politique
c'est ce qu'on dit et fait il ya aussi
on a vu aussi vendre dans ce débat un
peu comme si on regarde l'image une
sorte de renouvellement quand même delà
de la classe politique ça c'est plutôt
positif pour le groupe
oui nous mêmes se connaissent pas vous
identifie pas encore tout à fait une
super je trouve qu'on va finir par
regretter les hommes crédibilité de du
temps d'avant de l'ancien temps comme
dirait ma combat ce qui est franchement
je devais faire
marais à coups en tout cas regretter
quelque chose l'ancien temps oui allez
on y va
donc si je vais regretter quelque chose
de l'ancien temps ça serait les
anciennes émissions politiques c'est à
dire comment est ce qui me manque
beaucoup c'est elkabbach avec georges
marchais c'est ce temps qu'on avait
pourparlers pour rencontrer la
personnalité avant même le programme
c'est à dire qu'on s'est attaché à la
personne
voilà sachant qu alors la régulation du
csa vous l'avez rappelé elle est très
stricte mais néanmoins hors période
électorale alors en période électorale
c'est à dire quinze jours avant
l'échéance
il faut une égalité stricte sinon
auparavant c'est une et cliquer il
détend paradoxe et qui est mesurée par
rapport à votre poids politique
donc on n'avait pas besoin d'entendre
par exemple benoît hamon aussi longtemps
aura ses intentions devant toi sinon n'a
notamment alors le tribunal
administratif s'était fondée sur la
régulation pluralisme et c'est vrai
qu'on doit normalement attendre un
pluralisme des courants d'idées mais ça
va tout à fait avec des émissions
individuelles donc moi je ne comprends
pas pourquoi maintenant la nouvelle mode
et d'entendre tout le monde en même
temps c'est la seule solution pour être
sûr de n'entendre personne et je crois
que c'est une erreur de programmation
quand on voit comment a fonctionné
l'émission de cyril hanouna avec marlène
ce qui a pas ça prouve que on ne peut
plus entendre parler de politique comme
ça alors de là à en arriver à l'émission
de cyril hanouna france 2 je pense qu'il
ya encore une très grande marge
mais il faut arriver à retrouver un
temps calme en politique j'ai été assez
choqué aussi la manière dont le
présentateur thomas sotto avait de
recadrer un petit peu violemment des
personnes stabilité en étant un petit
peu maître d'école en disant bon
maintenant ça suffit pensez à vos
électeurs qui vont être cernée demain la
preuve quand on va au bout du coup on
est fatigué mais c'était ridicule
à mon sens on
on met plus en valeur la parole
politique on essaye de les mettre en
défaut et je crois pas qu'on puisse
obtenir un débat sain dans ce contexte
c'est en réalité c'est comment la
politique est faite et elle est faite à
partir du format qui a été créée par les
journalistes et moi alors bon this house
télévision qui est un peu salée et moi
les des mauvaises bois pour le coup
parce qu'ils aient d'autres mois dans la
télévision n'est pas obligé de l'homme
ça fait faire ma fatigue et une volonté
du buzz une volonté d'imagés 91 on veut
plutôt on a commencé l'émission chacun
devait ramener un objet on a eu des mots
note on a eu des je ne sais quoi chacun
de son objet de minutes pour passer pour
objet on est inquiet pour le coup il y
avait un camion maintenant c'était
bellamy et puis l'iliade et l'odyssée se
trouve enfin des gens qu'elle est un
pays de 10 ans et d'un côté lors de la
c'est quand même pour des questions choc
on leur demande de répondre par oui ou
par non
on me pour ont mais contre le seul qui a
voté vers tout le monde me rouge en vue
alors pourquoi etc
puis les autres les bras croisés enfin
il ya ce côté vraiment où le débat
caricature on veut tout de suite une
réponse une réponse tranchée définitive
on crée pas les conditions du dialogue
et puis il ya un mépris aussi des
journalistes je trouve visage du
personnel et qui tous bancs confondus
d'ailleurs c'est enfin on les coupe au
tribunal les deux procureurs
quant à la remontée des égouts avoue
quelques minutes pour parler on les le
couple ont fait la petite phrase pour
dire voilà on rectifie on donne la
parole à quelqu'un la personne peut pas
répliqué c'est moi je trouve que les
choses bougent beaucoup de choses aux
responsables politiques
mais en réalité je trouve que
les responsables politiques sont mis
dans des conditions qui rend justement
impossible l'exercice de leurs fonctions
c'est simple puisque au lieu de jouer
les maîtres d'écoles vont la vivre
le rôle des journalistes parce qu'il ya
quand même des erreurs qui sont utiles
dans ces débats avaient défait news etc
ça serait de corriger ce serait de dire
la vérité sur quand même des gens nous
dise des mensonges éhontés et donc il ya
double pris vis-à-vis des cons il avait
raison mais je pense quand même viser
aussi de aussi des téléspectateurs qu'on
prenne pour des cons quoi mais non ça
aussi le fact checking où les faits qui
news je pense que en fait je ne sais pas
qui a fait la poule qui a fait l'oeuf
mais à force de vouloir contrôler la
véracité des chiffres et des
informations là encore on me know he is
le rôle du politique on le met en défaut
on le note et ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui moi profondément me choque
puisque du coup maintenant il faut
préparer des fiches
alors on reproche aussi par exemple on a
reproché à raphaël glucksmann de lire
ses notes mais il ya tellement de
données chiffrées sur lesquels vous êtes
attendus à la suite d'un petit twitter
qui va vous dire que vous avez quelques
comiques et les choses des landes celle
là là aussi ça va mieux avec les
fabulations il contient france
oui au mensonge c'est pas mal en ce sens
jusqu'à quand et peut-être les
journalistes peut-être aussi de
connaître un peu les dossiers millions
toujours par du comté niant l acquis
rien il n'a pas été repris par un jeune
nordiste en semaine parce qu'ils
connaissent aucun de 6 1 me soit là pour
faire le maître d'école s'est très bien
après sinon sur le fond c'est que donc
c'est tout sauf un débat c'est ce que
nous devons dire
et en plus
là j'ai encore un paradoxe est que
arrive des personnes qui ont l'habitude
de débattre sur le fond et sur le fond
idéologique et je pense qu'il ya un vrai
besoin de ça pour contrer ça on peut
aussi si un politique prendre la
décision de ne plus y aller donc ça peut
être une décision
raphaël glucksmann quand il dit à la
sortie je ne suis pas fait pour ça il a
peut-être raison de le dire et on peut
attendre de ces gens là c'est comme un
mouvement de balancier
il faut qu'on sorte justement de ce
spectacle et qu'on revienne sur le débat
d'idées est facile c'est passéiste mais
ça a bercé même mon adolescence c'est le
legend
en plus on n'a plus droit de ces de
s'étriper un peu c'est à dire le débat
c'est la contradiction et on nous
appelle ça de voler vers c'est
impossible avec le type même quand il y
en a peu
ce qu'on attend c'est de l'invectivé un
petit mot mais pas le contre est validé
mais quelques belles amies lui sort
plutôt grand dink de 2,2 ce temps
politique parce que depuis quelques
semaines j'ai fait une sorte de sans
faute après on peut adhérer ou pas ses
idées mais sa façon de s'exprimer de
refuser effectivement la petite phrase
de refuser de 2,2 invectives de refusé
de critiquer systématiquement ce qui
vient de du parti adverse etc
on a l'impression d'un type qui
réfléchit un peu qu'un peu apaisé qu'il
est ok bah voila moi je pense pas que
représente sa après vous aimez ou pas on
peut en discuter et ça c'est assez c'est
très agréable quand on a l'impression et
il n'y a pas ce côté glucksmann
effectivement qui débat où j'ai pas fait
pour ça bon bah lui il n'était pas non
plus fait pour ça et il a l'air de bien
s'y mettre et je trouve que c'est assez
plaisant il était apolitique il était
déjà aux affaires
oui mais enfin c'est 10 heures c'est six
épreuves dont on sent qu'on change quand
même de l'arrivée mais dans mon cou dans
cette émission et lépine longtemps
peut-être un coup politique a droit
devaux quai de changer de registre
exactement et de placer sur le devant de
la scène pour ces élections quelqu'un
qui est laid par antinomiques mais en
tout cas qui est très différente mais le
point titrait la semaine dernière
l'homme qui règne à droite c'est pas
m'aimer mais christian jacob qui était
un des plus fervents opposants à la
nomination de belém l'intellectuel les
revient deux sur dix nommés il revient
dessus mais finalement c'est
probablement une bonne idée parce que il
il renouvelle le genre il est bien il
est intéressant et intelligent il est
valable donc c'est beaucoup 2002 enfin
d'autres dans le proche du dd
républicaine ou républicain qui était
pas fan
alors on essaie de désignation et qui ya
une chose qu'il a réussi à mon avis dans
une période assez perturbé pour les lr
c'est d'arriver une forme de synthèse
c'est à dire que finalement on a le
sentiment qu'il a sa position alors
qu'il ya le problème c'est le faux
problème c'est que voilà si vous prenez
le programme bel air vous avez des mois
la mesure macro et vous avez des mesures
réalistes de l'autre côté que comme il
n'arrive pas à choisir entre l'un et
l'autre qui veulent capter des deux
électorats
ce programme est pas clair je crois que
c'est ça qui les banques dans les
sondages d'ailleurs parce que on voit
quand même que les deux qu'ils sont en
tête
c'est la liste renaissance les rues m
très pro européenne et la liste
rassemblement national tu es anti
européenne mais c'est pour ça que je
voulais dire c'est qu'à mon avis sont sa
réussite personnelle c'est d'avoir déjà
réussi à s'imposer en tant qu'outsider
et d'avoir fait une forme de synthèse
entre toutes les micro famille de sa
famille mais au moins ça l'obligé à un
grand écart de bruges va forcément très
visible et sa renoue avec la question
qu'on a posé des philosophes contre les
petites phrases
est ce que dans un débat aussi passionné
que celui de l'europe on n'a pas besoin
finalement de position claire tout noir
ou tout blanc et ça prouve que
finalement les deux seuls partis qui
arrive à se faire entendre qu'ils ont un
débat audible ce sont ceux qui ne sont
pas forcément dans la nuance et qui ne
sont pas forcément dans le fond
philosophique mais qui au moins arides
malheureusement donné qu'ils ont des
positions très reconnaissable qu'on voit
à peu près une chose que nous pouvons
relever aussi une dans cette
multiplicité de douze acteurs c'est que
c'est la difficulté justement à trouver
des convergences oui alors c'est une
élection pour un parlement européen on
doit trouver des solutions ensemble et
en plus compétents c'était un parlement
dans lequel il ya beaucoup d'alliances
beaucoup de voilà donc là on arrive déjà
avec 12 candidats avec des gens pour
trouver la différence il faut quand même
être très fin analyste politique et
autre chose également c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui viennent à une élection pour
dire ouvertement qu'ils sont contre
l'europe
enfin lancé à ceux complètement mis un
paquet parmi les douze d'explosifs celle
ci se trouve c'est pas paradoxal quand
on peut être candidat aux élections
présidentielles justement pour dire je
veux passer une nouvelle république
parce qu'après on a appuyé me fait trop
de pouvoir il n'y a pas en disant je ne
veux pas être président de la république
non mais là comme cet acteur qui disent
je suis contre longwy laisser rentrer
dans un système qu'on le détruire c'est
aussi et après ça serait bien quand ils
sont élus y siègent
oui ou non plus nous payons tron
engagements ont tous pris un engagement
souhait la rive non mais je veux dire il
ya beaucoup d'absentéisme dans les
partis en plutôt anti européen et lui
ouvre même côté des fonds européens pour
le travail il ya un petit sont à dire
c'est que c'est vrai que ce qu'on a dit
sur la cacophonie des partis politiques
étaient totalement réel c'était
affligeant de voir autant de micro micro
penser mais surtout rappelé aussi la
particularité du parlement européen qui
est composé uniquement de partis de
coalition
puisque justement comme c'est un
parlement qu'on pourrait qualifier de
fédérale en tout cas qui fédère
l'ensemble des parties et à bignan on
peut pas avoir un parti socialiste parti
renaissance et donc précisément les
familles politiques au parlement
européen me semble beaucoup plus
cohérente que celle qu'on a en france
c'est à dire que vous avez une famille
plus démocrates une partie plus centré
sur les questions sociétales plus
environnementale et même pas pour ce
débat là on arrive à se mettre d'accord
et je suis totalement avec vous
d'accord avec vous c'est triste de
l'image qu'on va renvoyer à l'union les
problèmes aussi par exemple ou pve avec
urban et c est ce qu il faut dissoudre
dans pas de danse à 16 et le problème
après c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
finalement ça sera peut-être ça la
nouvelle démocratie se dire la
célébration il y aura plus de candidats
que d'électeurs n'ont pas eu un mot
peut-être sur le remaniement ministériel
avec une députée puis deux très proches
collaborateurs du président de la
république impression que ça ça se
resserre c'est un mini en me maintenant
ça me conseillez quoi
oui faisait peut-être un peu méchant la
veut dire ça parce que non c'est
monsieur o il ya rien il ya rien
d'aberrant là dedans après tout le monde
se focalise un petit peu sur site bête
sendai de l'air d'avoir un certain franc
et merlot jobs démarre elle démarre
enfin bon après pc des communications
quand même non alors c'est vrai qu'elle
avait aussi dit répondant à une question
sur le des obsèques nationales ou pas de
simone veil est la meuf est morte ce
matin on verra c'est vrai que c'est un
peu un peu curieux et puis il ya une
autre phrase qui m'a interpellé aussi
alors j'ai pas réussi à savoir c'est un
poisson d'avril ou pas il paraîtrait
qu'un moment et les 10 e suis prête à
mentir pour protéger l asile c'est un
peu compliqué pour un porte-parole de
voilà ça peut le faire mais il faut pas
le dire en tout cas bien qu'on monte au
cerveau cela dit c'est plutôt oui mais
ça du collier mais quelques bonnes idées
des choses à prendre aux états unis aux
etats unis un porte parole vous n'avez
pas le droit de mentir de porte parole
des officiels mans un mensonge de dire
c'est un délire pain du diable ce soit
le président voilà oui c'est rayonner le
portant à parlera de mentir aux états
unis on parle de du président alors que
en france gea bastia si en plus elles
l'avouer je me suis prête à monter c'est
dommage ça dévalue un peu le dessus
après tout cette garde rapprochée
l'acquérir au gouvernement c'est un
un sentiment quand même un peu de
solitude ou de moi personnellement je
trouve c'est que en effet ses traits en
marche et c'est trés première famille
dans ma loge donc en effet à mon avis ça
veut dire que déjà le parti pris qui
avait été le sien au départ d'aller
composé plus loin et d'essayer démontré
ce serait un gouvernement d'ouverture
est déjà là complètement abandonné et
puis ça prouve aussi que on n'a plus
vraiment de personnel qui a en vue de
s'engager en politique donc on est
obligé de prendre parmi les plus proches
pour avoir alors sa foi aussi peut-être
avec l'acte 2 e justement du mandat d'
emmanuel macron dont il a plusieurs fois
parlé qui prouve que maintenant il
entend encore plus affirmé sa couleur
politique
néanmoins la question se pose aussi à
nouveau de l'expérience de 2 c en marche
l'explosion et salle expose à mon sens
encore plus ce qu'il faut aussi rappeler
c'est que on dit voilà un conseiller
peut devenir ministre c'était pas une
bonne chose il faut rappeler que le
président lui avait été conseillé
françois hollande il est ensuite devenu
président et la deuxième chose c'est que
à mon sens on a beaucoup plus de pouvoir
des responsabilités en étant conseiller
du président république qu'en étant
ministre est possible ça c'est évident
aussi pour la presse et pour leurs
pensées pour la presse oui mais comme
conseils des 10 et oui ça c'est bon j'ai
pas d'opinion force sur le sujet jeune
parlons de nouveaux visages également
aussi je crois que ces six dans l'air du
temps donc d'accord maintenant
là aussi on s'éloigne du fond encore une
fois et
c'est ce qu'une sommes en train de faire
on parle de surface la chose c'est une
apparente quant à l' isolement d'un
dirigeant et notamment d'un président de
la république je crois qu'une façon ça
c'est évident c'est une épreuve très
grande solitude et à la solitude et puis
il ya le on était bien que par serge est
venu dans même là on voit bien dans le
camp pour parler un peu du grand débat
si vous voulez mais avec c'est lui qui
le branche à ce qu'il va leur rencontre
qu'il est un peu seul maintenant
l'impression quand même tout et c'est
peut-être la loi du quinquennat on en a
parlé souvent mais tout remonte à lui
tout part de lui quoi ça c'est vraiment
affaiblir l'institution présidentielle
qui a été créée pour éviter c'est
exactement ce qu'il est en train de
faire un présent la république qui au
regard de la constitution article 5 a
arbitré le garant de la région est
vraiment en dehors du jeu politique
et là on a quelqu'un qui ce mot qui va
répondre qui va demander aux quidams de
lui donner sa fiche de salaire pour
vérifier ici respondi répondent bien aux
conditions du décret et qui régissent la
situation on n'a plus cette protection
qui doit intervenir entre président et
le peuple français avec un premier
ministre fusible et un président qui
garde sa hauteur alors sans s'enfermer
non plus à l'élysée mais qui dans sa
posture son discours à quelque chose qui
est national
voilà pour moi c'est vraiment le retour
de l'hyperprésidence on en a beaucoup
parlé pour nicolas sarkozy qui pourtant
avait quand même réussi à déléguer pas
mal de choses à ce ministre parle pas de
son premier ministre qui était assez
dévaloriser mais à ses ministres qu
avait quand même des des responsabilités
ici on a vraiment le sentiment que
jupiter est revenu c'est à dire que
précisément c'est lui qui a pris en
charge le tout j'ai lu dans un article
que c'était le président n'ont pas de
l'omniprésence mais de l'omniscience et
je pense à la fois que ça fait partie de
sa personne parce que
il a l'air de pouvoir voilà avoir une
capacité de travail dont on a déjà
gloser plusieurs fois de pouvoir être à
l'aise sur beaucoup de sujets mais est
ce que ça ne lui donne pas un petit peu
le sentiment de tout savoir et de
pouvoir tout diriger j'ai peur que ce
soit que finalement ça voilà que sa
qualité ses 50 tenir le coup voilà non
c'est un peu ce que je donc les français
avaient besoin enfin les états où il
faut se souvenir que s'il était élu il y
avait comme un enthousiasme à ces
énormes et j'en étais totalement séduit
par ce jeune type sa personnalité et
c'est donc c'est peut-être contraire à
l'esprit de la constitution mais ça me
semble paraît tout à fait cohérent avec
les d'esprit des gens aient la volonté
de fer que j'aime beaucoup de voir
philippe mais on n'a pas voté pour
edouard philippe
on a voté enfin la veille les français
ont voté pour emmanuel mâcon dont ils
ont envie d'un jeune dit qu'ils avaient
à peine 40 ans on n'a pas envie de le
voir ce ce chirac ise et ne rien ne rien
faire parce que contradictoires il ya
quand même une demande un peu monarchie
en élection présidentielle quelqu'un qui
a eu le dessus en même temps s'il est un
peu trop beau tu en effet nous avait
raison quand la rue demandait qu'est ce
qu'il fait il convient très bien
c'est vrai les dons sont contradictoires
et donc la région se retrouvent
qu'honnêtement il a quand même vraiment
est là pour une fois je vais être de
l'avis de votre ami bayrou il
il a remarquablement bien
repris la main avec l'épisode des gilet
jaune avec cette omniprésence sur le
grand débat et c'est parce que je veux
dire après l'épisode 3 il était
totalement dans les souffre plus
personne ne pouvait pas prononcer le nom
de macron sans que les gens sortent la
gousse d'ail le crucifix et puis là tout
d'un coup maintenant et il est revenu un
peu en haut du truc
il ya moins de détestation n'y a pas de
tous les lionceaux médiane ni du
président pour pouvoir en france en tout
cas il ya un côté encore très royaliste
pour pouvoir mieux lui couper la tête
il ya quelques mois on lui reprochait
d'être loin du peuple
là il est il en est sans doute trop près
ils lui ont valu reprochés
bon je crois que en tout cas il faut
effectivement être très très fort et en
plus il a plus le temps d'aller au ski
non c'est quand même c'est quand même
difficile il est vrai que la définition
de la vème république c'est une
monarchie on coupe la tête d'euros tous
les ans on peut ne pas se voir couper la
tête si on arrive à trouver cet
équilibre
je pense que pour le coup lui fait
vraiment le grand écart où ils étaient
totalement absents totalement invisible
je plains jupitérien je ne prends pas la
parole etc puis là d'un coup il arrive
dans le débarras il va partout ils
parlent de tout et c'est incroyable et
là c'est selon lui demander d'intervenir
un peu plus ce n'est pas à ce niveau là
non plus et puis d'avoir une parole
présidentielle qui soit une parole
national global pas quelqu'un qui vient
répondre à la situation particulière de
chacun il faut avoir une vision qu'ils
au gré des différentes choses qui
m'interpellent un petit peu dans cette
manière de mouiller la chemise et
d'aller devant les maires de france
c'est que ça n'était pas du tout prévu
dans le programme du grand débat déjà
puisque le grand débat était censé
normalement appartenu aux français pour
que ce soit eux qui proposent donc ça ça
change un petit peu la logique et il ya
une deuxième chose c'est que le
président aime beaucoup les expressions
un peu old school comme ça à mon avis il
est en train de nous vendre le miroir
aux alouettes c'est à dire que la fin du
grand débat c'est le sujet tabou
personne ne sait ce qui va sortir de ces
trois mois de discussions et de ses
quatre heures qu'il a passées à chaque
fois devant tout le monde c'est bien
d'écouter
c'est bien quand c'est pas 5 ou 6 août
est c'est bien de montrer qu'on peut
travailler jusqu'à très tard et écouter
tout le monde mais c'est bien d'en faire
quelque chose et
a profondément sur dix pensent que ça ne
le devrait des bonnes servir à rien
attendons attendons d'abord pour juger
et puis on peut pas tout reprocher
toujours à ce pauvre président c'est à
dire que tout le monde a dit oui c'est
scandaleux les gens les plus
intéressants de la peau du du personnel
politique en france ce sont les mères
c'est merveilleux on les écoute pas
assez on les méprise c'est là il va leur
parler pendant six heures maintenant on
dit mais c'est ridicule ça résume andré
savoir ce qu'on veut je les reçois les
maires ccc une quantité négligeable
quand on on continue à dire on s'en fout
mais l'avenir on lui dit les mères n'est
pas fait assez attention il va les voir
et on est encore en train de râler c'est
comme merveilleux c'est des rumeurs
avaient quand même demandé à être écouté
auparavant sur les besoins qui étaient
les leurs alors que là on est content le
président parler de ce qu'il estime être
bon tout la phrase c'est lui qui dit
c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas parlé du
chômage et du terrorisme
attention les les revendications des
maires de france étaient des
revendications fiscales et financières
qui n'ont toujours pas été écoutés donc
les mêlées mer en bretagne ils ont pu
dire ce qu'ils ont voulu pendant six
heures je dirais oui après je dirais on
peut reprocher ce qu'on veut mais je
veux dire c'est au maire de s'exprimer
quand on est face au président de la
république ils ont six heures pour
s'exprimer
6-6 il n'arrive pas à organiser leur
pensée c'est un de problèmes mère
d'accord mais à trans cas-là ça aussi
c'est différent du grand débat on nous
vend beaucoup de choses pour cent une
labellisation qui n'a pas forcément de
consistance à ce grand débat c'est pas
non plus un règlement comme ça avec les
articles article 2 le 3 c'est son nom
mais c'est comme ça voilà on verra ce
que j'ai pu m'en sortir mais ya pas de g
j'ai tendance à penser mais voilà c'est
ça sera mon petit moment anti grand
débat même si beaucoup de français ont
participé que c'est une bonne chose
je suis assez sceptique par rapport au
processus de participation du public
parce que je trouve qu'il ya toujours un
moment de récupération ici du coup il ya
ces espèces de stand-up du président
devant les maires de france qui ont une
utilité ou qu'ils ont fait remonter dans
les sondages qu'on peut être reconnecté
la confiance mais qui à mon avis
privatise un petit peu ce grand débat et
le prix de son sens
est ce que ça donnera quand même quelque
chose je ne demande qu'a démenti josiane
je pense que c'est aussi
lyon pâques sont des hommes politiques
et que la politique c'est un art
difficile
là pour le coup il lui était reproché de
pas être assez près assez près des mers
donc un exercice entre guillemets et non
démocratique et la frustration par
rapport aux résultats d'un grand débat
mais je pense qu'elle est liée d géré à
la demande initiale c'est qu'on peut
qu'est ce qui peut sortir d'un grand
débat hormis de débattre et c'est ça
l'intérêt de table ça a permis aux gens
finalement de lâcher de l'expression et
c'est mieux de sortir des mots et maux
ts que des mots x plutôt que d'être dans
un escalier ça 2 je pense que c'est ça
aussi la grande vertu politique
alors après les mêmes c'est une
influence globale parce que ça a permis
justement de minimiser l'impact de la
violence est en tout cas de retrouver
pour le coup du dialogue les hélicos
vous avez à dire qu'il y avait une crise
quand même de la démocratie il ya que
les partis politiques de jouer le rôle
qui était de dérivatif des violences et
des haines et le grand débat était une
façon de prendre leur place vous encore
une fois sur le résultat il ya une trois
revendications et au départ du mouvement
mêmes initiales si on repart au 17
novembre lisf le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et la taxe carbone
d'accord ce sont les trois choses dont
on est sûr qu'elle ne bougeront pas à la
suite de ces heures de débat discussion
donc est ce qu'on a vraiment donné une
solution aux problèmes qui étaient à
l'origine c'est ça auquel je ne crois
pas néanmoins je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous on a apaisé on a
aussi montré qu'on était capable de se
renouveler
c'est une bonne chose mais le résultat
va-t-il pouvoir donner une solution à la
sortie de la crise je n'en suis pas
convaincu
nanterre le rics est pas forcément une
mauvaise idée c'est que c'est pas parce
que nous sommes aimés des idées
vêtements saugrenue grave et on va le
faire banon mais en fait non content on
va fléchir dire plus tôt qu'on ne le
ferai pas est ce qu il fallait qu et
d'émettre des idées voilà deux minutes
et demi juste un an vous avez le
sultanat de brunei qui prévoit la
lapidation pour punir des relations
homosexuelles et nombreux nay et
propriétaires de certains hôtels de luxe
parisiens débarquent un certain nombre
de gens de monde de boycotter à notre
avis c'est une bonne idée
ben mouaïa de il ya deux choses qui me
choquent bhl est bien évidemment il ya
ce qui se passe dans le sultanat qui est
absolument révoltant des scandaleuses
après sorte de postures des vedettes qui
disent on va boycotter deux palaces il
en reste 12 à paris vers ça va pas
changer leur vie c'est pas la soupe à
force ils ont rien à craindre je dis
reliera il y aura toujours du monde
dedans et je préférerais que des
personnalités comme georges clooney face
à la limite d'une conférence de presse
pour vraiment s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils
pensent de cet islamisme hyper radicale
de cette façon de voir les choses et là
ça aurait dû du poids mais las espèce de
petit effet de manche le danger vous
irez plus au plaza ben oui le futur on
s'en fout ça ne changera rien au monde
ça changera rien ce qui se passe à
brûler alors que kiki dise clairement ce
qu'ils reprochent à 7 à cette religion
et cette façon de vivre cette religion
et là on arrivera à quelque chose
c'est une réponse économique à un
problème politique donc je suis d'accord
on est sûr de dialogue complètement
différent et je suis pas sûr que ça
amène quelque chose néanmoins là aussi
dans une dans un monde des petites
phrases et des petites actions
voilà ça montre que
il ya des pays des droits de l'homme qui
sont contre cette vision des choses mais
c'est pas un scoop mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui a connu qu ils veulent plus
y aller pour ne pas y être photographié
ses seconds ont parlé des gilet jaune je
pense que sur la totalité des gilets
jaunes je veux dire ont-ils déjà entendu
parler du plaza est ce qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'y aller un genou est ce
qu'à cause de george clooney - diabate
finalement je n'irai pas prendre un
brunch à 90 euros
ah mais c'est ballot 20 livres in
business club au nom un au royaume uni
sont au golf de la boue lycée qui est
très sympathique très bien mais en tout
cas c'est entre sa la vertu de mettre le
focus sur le sujet oui absolument
ça veut parler quand même ça fait
prendre conscience mais on a vu jusqu'où
ça peut aller avec
les hashtag toutes sortes de films donc
ça peut aller très très loin ça peut
aller loin il faut parler du qatar il
faut aller au parc des princes on s'en
sort plus après vous avez merci merci
beaucoup à notre président a versé au
mondial merci beaucoup sur baptiste du
cac et jean-charles jeudi je rappelle
les oubliés n'oubliez pas à bien
[Musique]